well we're talking with eric palacios
about evictions during the pandemic a
lot of people have struggled
to pay rent and there has been a
moratorium on evictions and here's more
on that
eric there is a moratorium right now
on addictions but that's not going to
last a whole lot longer when are we
going to start seeing
evictions well the governor made an
announcement uh last week that he is
going to extend the moratorium until the
end of march
so if you are in danger of uh being
evicted of losing
uh your rental space your home uh
because of non-payment of rent uh you're
protected
at least until the end of march uh is
there any reason a landlord could
evict a tenant before then yes the
moratorium is not all-inclusive the
moratorium is only for
non-payment of rent so if your contract
is up if you had a one-year contract and
that has expired in your month to month
your landlord can choose not to continue
the contract if you violate any clause
in the lease if you have pets that were
not
stipulated or not allowed if you had
more people on the property if you're
conducting a business that you shouldn't
be conducting in the property or if you
violate
any law you can be evicted for cause for
those reasons
so what advice do you have then for both
landlords and for tenants
well it's important to to know that this
is not a rent forgiveness
if you are haven't been able to work if
you can't make your rent payment
it doesn't mean that this debt is going
away you still owe it
you simply need to make arrangements
with your landlord to pay it back
as soon as possible if you're a landlord
and your tenant isn't paying
the rent then it's important to
communicate with them and to see why
this is happening and if there's any
type of uh arrangement or agreement that
can be reached between the two of you
yeah so if a lieutenant has not been
able to pay rent
uh for some time now that debt is just
accumulating right
that's correct it's accumulating uh the
interest and
penalties might be waived in the future
uh
by a judge but the rent is still going
to be due
so it's important to keep this in mind
you don't want to take advantage of the
system if you're still working if you're
still able to
make the payment don't take advantage of
the situation and not pay rent
it's going to bite you in the end you're
going to have to pay it
as always great information eric really
appreciate you joining us
thanks for having me take care for more
information you can give eric palacios
and associates a call that phone number
their website 702-444-7777
ericpalacioslaw.com